- Getting more and more excited.
More and more excited.
- Fire it up.
- Hold on D Rock give me one second.
Getting more and more
excited, about what we've got
planned for YouTube.
- Me too.
- Right?
- Yes sir.
- It's gonna get fucking good.
(rap music)
(background noise drowns out speakers)
(hiphop music playing)
There's just a complete lack
of practicality right now.
What I call fake
entrepreneurship. A lot of it.
- [Stephen] Well most
entrepreneurship today is fake.
- A hundred percent. Problem
is the five or ten that isn't--
(background noise drowning out speaker)
You see this in like the bubbles.
I mean real estate has historically
had these bubbles right?
And like the people that know
how to navigate them really
can win and that's what's
gonna happen in technology.
They'll be in these bubbles,
when the bubble burst in 2001,
and everybody ran to investment banking,
they should've tripled down.
That's where all the wealth was made.
If you knew, right,
think about it you're 32
you knew what you felt like
at 25, you're the same dude.
Same fire. Gets you real interesting man.
You make different decisions when you have
nine years patience, 13 years
patience, 20 years patience.
You sit with 77 year
old dudes who are like,
right, that was right?
They still have the fire.
He still needs you to
say yes you were right.
It doesn't go away, you know?
Right D rock?
- [D Rock] Yep.
- We're gonna look back at
this and we'll hug and like
I'm gonna be old as shit, no
hair, crumply Yoda looking,
and I'll be doing the same
shit I was doing right now.
It's gonna look exactly the same.
(hiphop music playing)
I just got off the phone Vaynersports.
Recruiting, recruiting, recruiting.
About to go on Instagram live.
Let me give you an update since
it's already 4:14 mountain time.
And, well actually you got
a little clip from the,
you saw my morning keynote
here at a sports owner conference.
Number three, expiring assets.
I am obsessed on how
sports continues to waste
their expiring assets.
To not have a hardcore
team in place to understand
on a second by second, minute
by minute, hour by hour basis
on how many seats are gonna be empty,
how many spots in the
stadium are gonna be empty,
what's happening in the parking lot,
this is all sawdust, and
can be converted into
incredible business conversion,
and I highly recommend
you get practical about
your empty whatever
in this environment and more importantly
this is an opportunity for you to act like
a media company and create content.
For example, every organization,
let's use the Chief's
since I'm looking at them.
You can literally search Kansas
City on Instagram right now
you can see the top nine people
that have posted a piece of
content on Instagram in the
Kansas City mile radius.
You can literally DM those
individuals and invite them
at scale not the one big
celebrity to sit courtside
who's on a TV show, the 14 hundred people
that live in the Kansas City
region who are not coming
who are not supporting
but you've got the assets
to literally talk to them one on one,
it's business development at scale.
And what they give you for
return on an expiring asset
is incredible, it doesn't take that much.
It doesn't take that much cost and effort
to add five more people to go
on the field prior to the game.
But the media that you get
in return for those five
posting content to the
30,000, 80,000, 900,000 people
that follow them, is disproportionate.
Just been networking and
gymming and a lot of good stuff
on that front just running the
business from my cellphone.
Meetings and phone calls all afternoon,
just very unusual for me
to be in the same place
more than 24 hours but
wanted to take advantage of
Steve Ross being here.
We've gotten a lot of quality time and
talking about our macro
strategies of the firm
over the next decade
and just meeting a bunch
of sports owners which is always fun.
And that's it, so I'm gonna
go on live right now D Rock.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Little different kinda setting.
Give me some different angles D Rock.
It's Instagram live session time.
- Why do I do lives?
- I think it's tremendous
engagement and interaction right?
You can create a lot
more of a relationship.
One on one like when you
know Taha presented Byrell.
It's just an opportunity
for me to engage at scale.
Instagram live's got a huge
audience, I mean here we are
already 14 hundred
people are watching this,
so, you know, in a snap
it gives me an opportunity
to engage and really at the end of the day
it's just a huge opportunity
to just to give back.
For me two core things that
I wanna get out of a live
is A for everybody to know
how grateful I am that
they even follow me on Instagram.
I think I'm stunned by people's
inability to be grateful
and thankful, I'm stunned that
people take it for granted,
the fact that six people
follow you on a social network
and wanna see what you have to say,
should humble you that six
human beings give a fuck.
So I want all 17 hundred
of these people right now
to know I give a fuck,
and I'm so grateful that
they give a fuck about my
content and then number two,
just answering shit right,
like, you know just,
you know what to start business in India.
That was a question, oh AJ's calling me,
god damn it AJ, just kill me. Hey bro.
(mellow electronic music)
Sometimes you got plans and
then they get fucking derailed.
Let's try this again. I'm back again.
William you are first, your green buds.
My green ear pods are
custom, Tyler got them,
somebody made them, I'm
not sure, how I got them,
but I know Tyler asked me do
I want them and I said yes.
Madelina good to see you.
- [Tyler] Colorwear.com
- Colorwear.com? That's cool.
What's going on everybody. Couple things,
one if you're not following my podcast.
And this is the Gary Vee Audio Experience.
You're making a great mistake of all time,
garyvaynerchuk.com has
all my events on it,
D Rock can you go to the
events page and give me some
knowledge on when I'm gonna
do my first trade show.
August 19 Boston, we've got
Frankfurt, Germany August 31st.
Frankfurt, Germany my
assistants coming to that.
No Matt just in between calls in my room.
How do I get my music to you?
I think D Rock's the best way JC World.
Oh D Rock said yep.
How do you accept fear of everything?
I just realized that anything
can happen at any point,
and so like you can either
be crippled by that,
or you can be empowered by that, and so,
just kinda how I think about it Jeb.
Good to see you, you've
gotta be down on my podcast
I'm about to do gangster shit on it,
I'm super pumped, Youtube in September,
what else is going on?
Oh we have a ridiculous
article coming out Colin and I
have been working on a beast about legacy.
Literally probably the
most effort I've put in,
and do you know how we're distributing it?
Ridiculously long blog post on Facebook.
Actually can you call Colin
real quick and ask him
when's it coming out?
I wanted it for tomorrow.
Yes, yes, yes, it is on Spotify,
it is on Spotify. Colin.
So as you guys already know
I have a secret coming out
in November, I'm very excited about.
The Gary Vee sneaker, you know
this like pretty basic stuff.
- [D Rock] Yeah.
- You know I've got that
deal coming out it's with
K Swiss I'm wearing some K Swiss Today.
I'm cramping, so this is not it.
That is gonna be awesome
I hope some of you rock
the Gary Vee I cannot wait
until the first person I see
at the airport wearing my sneaks.
And the new book Crushing It,
coming out in January 2018.
I'm excited about that.
- [D Rock] I can't believe
you forgot your suitcase.
- Oh my god did you
hear about my suitcase?
By the way you know how big this shirt is?
I couldn't wear this.
So guys I literally,
literally, you'll love this.
So I had two suitcases
coming out to Aspen.
I literally have no
clothes I have nothing.
It's like I can pack a suit
a fucking fuckin fuck. Fuck.
Alright, just text me and D
Rock a place to go buy shit.
See you. I have absolutely nothing.
You just needed to bring like,
like literally like sandels
and like a hat and like any
other one had all this stuff
and like I was on a call
and like you know somebody
on my team like threw
the wrong bag in there
so I literally showed up here,
so D Rock had to go and buy shit,
including this humongous
polo, doesn't fit,
all sorts of weird
shit, and like literally
I had to buy underwear, and like socks,
you know like, pretty awkward.
Pretty awkward situation.
(energetic hiphop music)
D Rock, speed it up,
you're gonna hear nothing,
one day hopefully I'll be
able to show you that entire
phone call it could end
up being ridiculous.
Two days in Aspen, tons
of Steve Ross time.
Keynote to a bunch of
boners from around all
four major sports and then some,
little cricket action for everybody
in that part of the world.
And just a ton of phone calls, operating,
making business decisions,
staffing strategies,
new business strategies, new
product offering strategies,
Vaynermedia, Purewow, VaynerX,
an exciting phone call
that you'll see footage
from that is secret,
that hopefully one day I
can release in the vault,
whether it happens or
not, we will release it
in seven or eight years,
yeah we should come up
with some timing on that.
Just very productive trip here to Aspen,
super excited about it, focused as fuck.
There's a lot going on.
I feel like we say that every day.
Guys sorry there's such limited
footage for this episode.
At this conference with all
the major sports ownerships,
and they kinda caboshed
the D Rock unfortunately
but very productive meetings,
networking, networking,
networking, reverse
engineer your finish line.
I know I wanna buy the
Jets, New York Jets,
if there's any confusion
in my professional life,
and so even though I hate
spending two days in one place,
this is the kind of place
I should be for that game,
and so whatever you
want in life, you know,
second home, ten trillion
dollar franchise,
just to fix your parents business,
make that line and work backwards,
and make every decision map to that,
that's what these next two days are about.
(energetic hip hop music)
Guys thank you so much, so much
for supporting my Youtube channel,
please subscribe if
this is your first time,
or if you've been watching and you haven't
fucking subscribed.
(laughing)